citizens of the reject Nation we leave
for the Guardians of the Galaxy 3
premiere in like 40 minutes so we gotta
rush to get this up and we got the help
of someone to help us cover the Hunger
Games who's a big fan of the hookers
actual literature person over here
Michael Tessler you did something do you
I'm bigger there's something different
about it did you get an all new teeth
I'm doing my Caesar flickerman well
leave a like for Michael's commitment
because he literally did it just for
this one trailer I also want to say uh
thank you to everyone who has followed
us at our patreon
um why are you mention patreon in this
video well recently uh all our videos on
patreon WE upload um everything in our
Vimeo and we're charging us a hefty bill
so with that in mind we got a sponsor
for today's video fellow Space Cadets
it's time to blast off into the final
frontier with the help of today's video
sponsor Star Trek Fleet command today's
video sponsor I've been playing this
game for the last 90 minutes so You Bet
Your Butt Talks I am ready to talk about
this game it's free to play open world
MMO game puts you in the captain's chair
of your very own star base on the front
lines of a Star Trek universe where you
can construct fleets of your favorite
chips and recruit legendary officers to
your crew explore strange new worlds
seek out new life and civilizations and
dominate the Galaxy with your powerful
Starships with the ability to customize
your Fleet and set your sights on
expanding your territory eliminating
Rivals exploiting resources and
exploring New Frontiers this game is the
perfect way to Unleash Your Inner Kirk
or Picard or data or many of the other
100 characters you can populate your
Fleet with imagine
commanding alongside your favorite
officers and living out all your space
exploration fantasies it's enough to
make a pharyngi grin from ear to ear I
pulled out one so get beamed up reject
Nation join the millions of players
already exploring the Galaxy building
their fleets and competing in Space
Battles click the link in the
description box or scan the QR code
right here on screen to download Star
Trek Fleet command today and boldly go
where no one has gone before I wanted to
pun-centric it a little bit you know
[Music]
John Wick
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean Casco oh no way damn I didn't know
he was in this
creators I've summoned you all here for
the 10th Annual reaping ceremony in
which we choose two children from each
district to fight to the death in The
Hunger Games from District 12. Lucy gray
bear is becoming a superstar man
there has been a change this year as the
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles no
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
start by thinking I can actually win
believe
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
he's doing great
enjoy the show what a Lo-Fi Hunger Game
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become Predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
oh my goodness the push
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
the fight against it we can step across
that line into evil I think that's 13.
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling that is not snow what is action
it's perfect perfect for this how
wonderful that we all get to be here for
someone's final performance
everything is about winning yes
[Applause]
I don't know
whoa and bird Gorman
the things we love most
Try Us
Color Me interested people
groovy
I not going to lie did not have much of
an interest in this really haven't wow
and that trailer just reeled me back in
yeah they cast their hook with their
marketing and they reel me back in for
some reason when I heard prequel I
thought that there wouldn't be any
actual hunger gaming here I was like oh
no there's like a Hunger Games thing and
I was reminded how the last couple
movies there was no actual hunger games
and then I'm like oh this is gonna be
cool this is an actual hunger games
again yeah uh so yeah like I don't know
the literature I've only seen the movies
but I I thought this was a great great
reminder of what's come before at the
same time you know getting some
familiarity with the Nostalgia of some
of the characters that we are familiar
with and it's always fun seeing like the
younger casting and whatnot uh it looks
like a better version of whatever the
hell that fantastic Beast franchise was
supposed to be because that's a great
point before we let you take this away
Michael John who's in the same boat as
me unless you've read the books did you
have not son of a better
uh no this this pulled me back in
especially because the first two Hunger
Games movies uh had my my interest in my
enthusiasm a lot more than the later two
and so this yeah just brought me back to
like the Intrigue of the world the
Vitality of you know the the conflict
that the games themselves present and
two seeing is what like 60 or 70 years
in the past from the Katniss stories so
like I also just love the blending of so
we should see young baby Katniss at some
point yeah baby
embryonic
75 when she competes
completely differently in this world
um and at first too I was like really
Cory Elena snow we're gonna
that guy but even if even his role in
this and then seeing how you know I
imagine how he kind of Begins the rise
to the status we see him in later movies
like I don't know this doesn't feel like
a contrived way to keep this going this
feels like another spot on the map that
we're shining a light on yeah it looks
like he starts off compassionate and
then you watch him grow into uh
cold-hearted son of a baby I always
thought he was the hero uh no I I have
always loved Hunger Games uh my crush in
high school was like you should read
this and so I did and she's like you
remind me of Gail uh and that's exactly
how it turned out for me so uh yeah I
lost that to a guy named after bread uh
what a sad way to go sorry but what'd
you think of this trailer Brothers you
got three minutes trailer uh well first
off
they set such a cool interesting tone of
the early capital and the early Pan Am I
love where the world still feels a
little dystopian it has this like retro
futuristic element that you don't quite
see in the original Hunger Games films
from like a style perspective like Count
Me In from a lore perspective like I'm
so jazzed about the and the amount of
World building that we saw even just in
this trailer was just like golden
um I don't want to spoil anything for
those that haven't read the book so I'll
be like super Broad in my like
contextual knowledge here did you read
the book yeah because that's what I say
all the time from every comic book and
every show I can't read I read it so
fast I don't want to spoil it for you so
I'm gonna be like bro bro
no no it's a super fair but I don't know
how to read Greg so I couldn't even if I
tried
time you have two minutes oh damn it uh
there is a really interesting the house
of snow oh which is ironic considering
you know some of our Game of Thrones
characters that are in the trailer uh
the house of snow has fallen from grace
and you have the future President Snow
uh who's really kind of given the mantle
to try to bring his family uh The
Prestige that they used to have uh and I
think seeing how a character who is
dynamic complex there's a lot going on
with President Snow I I recently
rewatched all three of The Hunger Games
and it really struck me like they hold
up they're really good
um and this is a fascinating Deep dive
uh in a lot of ways it mirrors Katniss's
story because it does feature a tribute
from 12 uh and if you re-watch the
Hunger Games with the context of this
narrative it makes President Snow's
actions uh and Arc all the more
interesting and so it's nice to see a
prequel that is going to feed into and
enhance a story rather than just telling
an extra story just because they want to
make more money yeah yeah well I'm
excited that Peter Dinklage Peter
Dinklage Peter I'm excited he's going to
be in this world he's the perfect kind
of actor for this I just rewatched
Infinity war or he's Eatery his greatest
role his greatest role ever and then his
biggest role the Rachel Ziegler uh
Zeigler Ziggler
[Laughter]
she's just like on the rise and
like she does phenomenal work
consistently back to back to back uh so
I'm really excited that you know she
gets to be the new Jennifer Lawrence get
her and Jenna Ortega together in
something and they'll fuse into like a
Megazord put them in a peanut butter
Factory I would love to see them dipped
in peanut butter and then mush them
together
with some jelly peanut butter was not
invented by Latino woman no it's true I
don't care why you guys accuse me of
racism I I just assume as a white person
always protecting myself Against Racism
George Washington Carver Critter peanut
butter
and the did he do the pistol sharpener
too
what was that one cartoon that's
oversimplified that guy's life so much
that would be the proud family this is
what I was worried about we gotta go to
the premiere thank you guys so much for
being here what do you think I told you
what I thought oh I'm talking to them
what did you think there's someone else
in the room when you said what did you
think and what do you think of the
trailer guys put it in the comments do
you like Michael's hair should this be
as permanent 73rd annual hunting games
John
um
follow him on you don't need to but I
need followers if you find me in public
follow me around for five minutes myself
and buy
foreign